j'ai quelques jours motorola a présenté
un nouveau smartphone un smartphone
pliable un smartphone différente de ce
que fait motorola et l'idée c'est de
ressusciter un de leurs anciens modèles
le razer l'accent le whizzer le motorola
razr qui était un téléphone à clapet et
là on arrive avec un smartphone à clapet
mais cette fois ci avec un écran pliable
donc ce que nous montrent motorola là
dessus c'est qu'ils sont capables
d'utiliser ce qui était en tout cas leur
succès et de l'adapter à la sauce 2000
pas parce que c'est bel et bien un
smartphone de 2020 qui sortira en 2020
mais ça je vous le dirai à la fin de la
vidéo je donnerai le prix vous aller
voir cette très intéressante notamment
contenu de la proposition technologiques
que nous fait motorola pour ce
smartphone pourrait donc un smartphone
de poche aux smartphones qui se plie qui
est un format compact qui tient très
facilement dans la poche et c'est
justement au tour de force qui fait par
motorola parce qu'ils profitent
justement cette technologie d'écran
pliable pour pouvoir l'adapter à l'adn
de la marque
[Musique]
on fait un petit tour du côté de
l'historique ou autour last un fabricant
de smartphones notamment fabricants de
smartphones qui est un très gros succès
dans les années 2000 qui était une des
marques références août à l'une des
marques référencées qui avec l'arrivée
du smartphone les gars n'a pas su trop
prendre le virage
motorola aujourd'hui proposent des
produits dans l'entrée milieu de gamme
du tout ski haut de gamme on ne retrouve
pas motorola et quand on pense
innovation smartphones tout de suite on
va pas se mettre à penser à motorola
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour motorola c'est
de montrer qu'avec ce réalisateur avec
ce nouveau réseau et sont toujours
présents ils sont là ils sont maintenant
levés ils sont des premières marques à
innover au niveau du smartphone à écran
pliable la techno des écrans pliables
pourrait donc être une nouvelle chance
pour motorola pour revenir en force dans
le game du smartphone et revenir enfin
sur le devant de la scène c'est pas si
évident que ça parce que même si la
proposition est alléchante même si on
oublie que motorola a fait un beau
boulot et que il ya un smartphone qui
ôterait quand on le regarde à une techno
qui est vraiment très intéressante ça va
pas être simple parce qu'il va y avoir
de réelles difficultés notamment au
niveau de la concurrence
si vous revenez en arrière dans une
vidéo que j'ai fait il ya quelques jours
je vous parle du samsung galaxy fold
deuxième garçon samsung a présenté très
rapidement lors de la conférence de
développeurs un nouveau form factor pour
ton smartphone pliable avec le galaxy
folle vous aviez un smartphone qui
s'ouvrait et qui vous proposer un seul
et grand écran là avec ce nouveau
facteur vous avez un smartphone qui se
plie format clapet exactement le même
facteur propose motorola avec son viseur
il va donc falloir que motorola soit à
minima au niveau de ce que propose
samsung là dessus avoir après
effectivement la différence qu'on va
avoir de point de vue purement
technologique en termes de
spécifications entre le produit de
samsung le produit de motorola
les finitions les spécifications et
surtout il finit le tarif
même si on n'est qu'un petit aperçu de
ce que pourrait être le fold vais de
nouveau form factor il paraît être en
tout cas un peu plus sexy que ce que
nous propose le motorola aujourd'hui
mais ça je vous le détailler pour voir
vraiment qu'elles sont un peu les points
de faiblesse de ce produit que ce qui
pourrait être rédhibitoire du côté de
chez motorola c'est cette grande bordure
que vous avez en bar vous le faire mais
les vous avez en bas une partie qui est
assez grosse attention quand même sur un
smartphone que j'ai pas pris dans les
mains donc c'est délicat tout de suite
de vous donner mon ressenti j'espère que
motorola me permettra de le tester pour
vous dire vraiment ce que j'en pense
mais lorsqu'on le voit comme ça on voit
qu'elle bordure en relief sur le bas ils
vous retrouver juste au dessus vos
petits boutons
android pour pouvoir revenir à l'accueil
gérez votre multitâche aux applications
j'ai peur que ce soit pas évident d'un
point de vue purement esthétique lorsque
vous l'ouvrez vous effectivement cette
bordure sur le bac est pas d'assez pour
imminente en relief un vrai volume alors
effectivement lorsqu'on vient le replier
ça a un sens ça s'intègre complètement
mais lorsque c'est ouvert c'est pascal
je mets un bémol parce qu'il faut
vraiment attendre de voir ce que va nous
proposer ça nous sommes là dessus mais
j'imagine qu'on aura un smartphone à
clapet qui va venir bord à bord sans
bordures en relief aux éminences gros
menton sur le ballon ça pourrait être
une des difficultés en tout cas pour
motorola cette grande partie sur le bab
à voir dans les temps à venir quoi qu'il
en soit il faut quand même saluer
motorola au niveau de l'innovation
motorola un réfléchir comment est ce
qu'on pouvoir intégrer tout ça comment
on peut utiliser la technologie des
écrans pliables pour l'intégrer à l'adn
de la marque est justement ils ont fait
un tour de force aujourd'hui ils parlent
de leur histoire ils racontent leur
histoire ils racontent l'histoire de la
marque et ils prennent tous aillent il
le pose en 2020 enfin quasiment parce
qu'on a quasiment un pied en 2020 en
tout cas d'un point de vue purement
technologique il le pose donc en 2020
les ans voilà qui ont des voilà d'où
l'on vient voilà notre histoire de
produits et voilà aujourd'hui ce qu'on
est capable de faire
utiliser le meilleur des technologies
actuelles on ne nous dénaturant pas et
hangar dont l'adn de la marque donc ça
félicitations motorola le produit en lui
même je trouve intéressant de par la
promesse qu'il fait l'idée d'avoir un
smartphone avec un grand écran convient
d'être essien qui a très facilement dans
une poche
ça peut réellement avoir un sens il faut
quand même savoir qu'ils ont testé pas
moins de vingt-six prototype pour
arriver au modèle final tel que vous le
voyez aujourd'hui
alors qu'est ce qu'on va quand on
regarde ayant effectivement un
smartphone à clapet sur le côté un petit
bouton on/off un bouton de volume
rien de bien d'un gosse sur le bas de
l'usbc une grille qui doit cacher bien
évidemment le micro et un haut parleur
sur le haut du clapet on voit une seule
caméra double flash led
lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous avez une
petite caméra qui est planqué à côté du
haut parleur sur le haut et lorsqu'il
est complètement ouvert qu'est ce qu'on
voit c'est que sur les côtés eh bien
vous avez un léger arrondi
vous avez une encoche même si le format
est vraiment cool ça me paraît quand
même dommage qu'on ait cette grande en
cauchemar lorsqu'il est ouvert on a un
écran oled de 6
de pouce si intéressant mais c'est plus
petit que ce comporte trois autres cas
sur beaucoup de smartphones actuels qui
ne se plient pas avec une résolution de
2142 par 876 xl au format 21 9ème quel
format cinémascope les formats très
allongée pour pouvoir regarder du
contenu vidéo tandis qu'à l'extérieur
vous avez un écran oled de 2,7 pouces
résolution de 600 par et 800 format 4/3
très petit tout petit c'est un écran
notification permis de voir vos sms qui
vous appelle de prendre une photo
lorsque vous refermez vous prenez avec
la caméra principale un format cette
fille mais pas plus parce que vous voyez
effectivement et que vous avez cette
grosse caméra votre petit écran au
dessus et c'est tout le côté c'est
complètement évident que vu vous allez
le faire mais il aurait très cyr et bien
vous n'avez pas beaucoup de place pour
mettre un seul et même grand écran donc
bon avoir un usage et ce qui est très
bizarre c'est qu'à l'intérieur vous avez
un processeur milieu de gamme
qualcomm snapdragon 710 si giga de ram
128 giga de stockage c'est surprenant de
se dire qu'on sorte un smartphone quand
même ce qui paraît très haut de gamme le
plus haut gain en tout cas du point de
vue finition du point de vue technologie
avec un écran pliable et nous mettre
qu'un qualcomm snapdragon 710 à
l'intérieur on sera tendu avoir un truc
hyper performant un truc un peu plus
puissant et bien non ça c'est très
bizarre peut-être que sur une v2 on
pourra voir qu'un peu plus puissant là
ça paraît quand même relativement mince
surtout compte tenu du prix mais ça je
vous en parle un peu plus tard dans la
vidéo du point de vue photo vous avez en
objectif principal a derrière une caméra
de 16 mégapixels tu ouvre à f
1.7 avec une stabilisation électronique
ici pas de stabilisation optique ça
c'est un peu embêtant ce qu'on a un seul
module photo l'arrière on en a pas deux
pas de tels objectifs
un autofocus du à pixels une mise au
point laser tandis qu'à l'avant
vous avez une petite caméra qui cachait
à côté d'un haut-parleur 5 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.0 5 mégapixels c'est
pareil ça me paraît quand même petit
joueur
je pense en terme de qualité ça va pas
le faire on a un capteur d'empreintes
digitales en basque justifie
effectivement cette grande bordures pour
venir le déverrouiller donc pas de
capteur sous l'écran du muntu 5.0 du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé et nous
annonce un smartphone qui est résistant
à l'eau n'y a pas du tout de
certification ip est par contre ce qui
est relativement embêtant car qui peut
l'être c'est que vous ne pouvez pas
mettre de na no 6 mais uniquement une
estime ça veut donc dire que votre
opérateur doit être compatible estime ce
nom vous ne pourrez pas utiliser
passer des coups de fil et recevoir des
sms alors les usages vont les voir c'est
effectivement un grand écran 21/9 oled
pour le multimédia ça c'est intéressant
par contre l'autonomie bottura nous
annonce une seule journée d'autonomie
avec une batterie de 2500 10 millions
terreur et de la recharge rapide de 15
watts j'irai uniquement 15 watts vous
donner qu'une seule journée une fois de
plus avec un smartphone qui propose qu
elle mue en termes de technologie avec
un écran pliable ça paraît un peu
dommage mais c'est le prix à payer pour
avoir un smartphone extrêmement fin et
bien évidemment un usage sont les
réseaux sociaux pas de gros usagers à
mon avis au niveau de la photo parce que
c'est pas là vous allez voir ce qu'il
sait mieux pas plus au niveau de la
vidéo ce que nous fassions vous n'avez
pas de stabilisation optique donc à mon
avis ça va être un petit peu moyen
insupportablement des points faibles de
ce smartphone
c'est un produit qui me semble en tout
cas pas être parfait loin d'être parfait
mais qui en tout cas fait de belles
promesses et c'est intéressant que
motorola se positionne sur cette
technologie des écrans pliables pour dit
ok on est là on existe on innove on
propose les dernières technologies
dernières innovations et sa smart phones
qui est annoncé au tarif de 1499 dollars
qui sortira en janvier 2020 on ne sait
absolument pas c'est un produit qu'on
pourra voir en france on n'a aucune
information là-dessus que dites vous
bien que 1499 dollars vous allez le
convertir en euros
vous allez rajouter les taxes c'est un
produit ne sortira pas en france il sort
un jour en france
un minimum à 1700 euros ça veut dire
qu'on vient flirter avec le galaxy fun
actuelle qui est plus performant plus
puissant qui sera meilleur en photo bon
voilà tout ça ça reste un petit peu à
voir je suis pas sûr que le prince il
faut vraiment vraiment intéressant à
voir bien évidemment une fois que ce
smartphone sera démocratisée
une fois que le form factor sera
démocratisée une facture à plus d'unités
vendues c'est pas m à de tirer les
tarifs vers la bande de gaza montrent
aujourd'hui que motorola est là et dans
la course continue à être présent à
innover proposer des choses
intéressantes et surtout faire parler de
la marque a vous de me dire ce que vous
en pensez en banque commentaire est ce
que vous seriez prêt vous à vous
positionner sur ce form factor de
smartphones qui se plie un écran de 6,2
pouces et qui se replient et qui est
tout petit qui tient facilement dans une
poche qui est fin et que ça pourrait
vous plaire
est ce que vous seriez prêt à débourser
une telle somme pour ce type au logis de
smartphones en sachant que vous n'avez
pas ce qui se fait mieux en termes de
performances skis c'est mieux en terme
de photos marc moutout sa campagne on se
retrouve dès demain pour continuer à
parler de textes nous au hamas à 2015